I was honest because I don't do like
wrong long-term relationship anyway I
[ __ ] somebody else say point someone
else yeah that is literally why that's
your honest answer I'll be all right
there are you yeah good things you
offers are sick
[Music]
[Music]
okay why do you agree happened because I
Fletcher foot golf the jaw joint no why
yeah Derek's there right so I don't like
do serious relationship so I'm not in a
relationship two years and I'm getting
on really well with you yeah and then
that [ __ ] me up I feel like what happen
was like obviously we've met a couple
times and it was going really well
and we were speaking as if like we knew
each other for years or whatever yeah
and it just came to the point where you
just vanished
yeah I mean like the messages was kind
of like it was days and days later
yeah I didn't send as many kisses anyone
I was trying to not hurt you but the
same time like if I don't text him back
he'll get the picture yeah but I didn't
get the picture you got on my Hollywood
you got a McGee from school remember
I know you Ricky but surely you would
have got the message that I'm not
texting you back well when you met me
give enough signals to to say you wanted
to meet me but when you didn't want to
meet me anymore when you went back to
abroad to work you could have just been
straight you know that's what I do ya
know it is but you just like me to let
you know yeah I feel like any person
would have liked it too late no I'm sure
you even blocked me on something I'm
sure you blocks gonna Instagram us when
you see me what are doing
yeah but exactly so if you're going for
that far process if you don't want me to
see what you do yeah but you missing le
what's going on are you sure because you
should be the person doing that you can
do whatever you want to do but the
common courtesy is to let somebody know
what's going on
[Music]
I think we've gotten really well-liked I
was shocked how well we got on yeah I
think I was the same of me it was weird
it was like we'd known each other for
years I feel like I'd probably strongly
agree usually but I didn't know
personally if that was a cop you if that
was the real you like to know well I
didn't yeah yeah exactly so
[Music]
rifle at our relationship had ended I'm
a bother
yeah I think that obviously you probably
gone out with loads of guys that you
found attractive in the past yeah
because it's been easy for you because
you have been the popular one you've
been attractive girl with me it hasn't
been like that
jammy and so when when I did get this
tinder come through and we matched and
stuff like that it meant a big deal to
me because I remembered you it's not
been you know a couple years it's been
like what 10 15 years that I've actually
known of you I understand where you're
coming from it was just totally me
because I'm Ellie I just wanna got me
because you thought oh she's a cool girl
from school I liked you you would have
never sung to me at school
Oh boys punch it in there everybody's
it's our choir because I went through
puberty
maybe yeah yeah I think I miss people a
bit too high in the test was I oh why do
you disagree cuz I feel like that so
what did you want for our relationship I
don't know in this wives this five chose
well sure that's just me off that's
actually piss me off I didn't know what
what I wanted I was eyes because I don't
do like wrong long-term relationship
anyway why not why because I always mess
to fall why because as soon as I get
close summer dad yeah I forget somebody
else say for me someone else yeah that
is my I could not be more honest with
you either I like your honesty I mess it
up if our be honest we had that probably
would mess it up
that is literally why that's your honest
answer
yes we said that
[Music]
I find you attractive yeah thank you
very attractive
I find you very I would sell in your
face any day I'd be the face I don't
want to ruin your face box it's on there
yeah I just like how kind-hearted you
are to be fair I feel like every
situation that you're in and wherever
it'd be like their taxi driver or like a
crowd of people you're the same person
you're not trying to like act to be a
person that you're not I feel that
sometimes you get nervous about
situations and stuff just about being
yourself whereas other people get
nervous about being somebody else all of
your eyes I love you smile I love the
fact that when we get attacks there
you're open door for me I've never met a
guy who has made me feel so important
you are amazing what is he sayin yeah
[Music]
I'm gonna see where it goes I hope that
some could be something good between
hours I would - I mean of a soft menu
than the occasion that we did I think if
we work it off there like we get on
super well and stuff yeah yeah we do
yeah we have a laugh every time that you
see each other you smile honestly it's
so contagious breakup dangers in the
science yeah yeah baby
they like the crowd and everything so
sorry what was that out of thing had -
hey babe
[Music]
in the 1960s you put men into a metal
rocket and you shot them through a
near-perfect vacuum 250,000 miles away
they landed safely on a rock 250,000
miles away and then came back and then
we just didn't go back that claim is
outlandish